[Music]
it's a pleasure to be here i feel this
is very strange that's most of us we're
not used to doing in-person events
things like this coming to them i've
only been to one uh before this in the
last two years i'm probably a different
person than i was in early 2020
but i don't feel that way it feels that
there's a continuous essence of me
that's persisted from then until
now
would i have noticed a change probably
not there could be something going on
like self-change blindness the
experience of being me changes
but i don't perceive the change and this
is an argument
that i want to leave you with at the end
of this talk and actually think it's
fundamental for understanding
consciousness of self and consciousness
of the world
that evolution has designed us to
perceive us to perceive ourselves as
more stable than we actually are because
all of perception is geared towards
keeping ourselves alive towards
regulating the body making sure we stay
alive we perceive the world around us
and ourselves within it with through and
because of our living bodies that's the
kind of take-home message before we get
started that's the argument i'm making
in the book
now thinking of things this way brings
up this puts brings up this issue of
consciousness of course this is an issue
that's on the table immediately
what is consciousness can we explain it
scientifically
will it always escape scientific methods
and so on and the definition of
consciousness that i like to start with
has to do with the philosopher thomas
nagle now thomas nagle he says it very
simply really and this goes back to the
1970s he says that an organism has
conscious mental states
if and only if there is something it is
like to be that organism
now there's something it's like to be me
there's something it's like to be you
there's probably something it's like to
be an elephant or a tiger or a kangaroo
there is probably nothing it is like to
be a table or an iphone or a glass of
water
or a simple robot these days there's
nothing going on for that system there's
no inner universe this could be
a very circular definition of
consciousness but at least gets us on
the same page consciousness is what goes
away when we fall asleep into a
dreamless state
or indeed probably more more true to say
what goes away under general anesthesia
and what comes back when we come around
or wake up it is not the same thing as
intelligence we don't have to be smart
to suffer
it is not the same thing as the ability
to generate complex
behavior it's certainly not the same
thing as having language although we
humans use language to talk about
consciousness so consciousness
fundamentally is any kind of conscious
experience
whatsoever which means that of course
there are other things
that can have conscious experiences
nagel's paper is well known for its
title more than anything what is it like
to be a bat there's something going on
for the bat
that makes it like something to be that
bad we will never
be able to experience badness for
ourselves but that's because we're not
bats now there's another inner universe
for bats going on
but can
science explain consciousness
on the face of it it seems that it might
not be able to
on the one hand we have
things that are made of stuff whether
they're tables or chairs or brains and
bodies
descartes called this uh res extensor
the world of the material and then on
the other hand we have
conscious experiences the experience of
redness the experience the sharpness of
the pain or the pain of jealousy
now these mental states don't seem to be
the same kind of thing that mechanisms
can explain descartes divided the
universe this way his basic insight has
been repeated many times over the years
david chalmers very famously talks about
the hard problem
of consciousness he says it is widely
agreed that experience arises from a
physical basis but we have no good
explanation of why and how it's so
arises why should physical processing
give rise to a rich inner life at all
it seems objectively unreasonable that
it should and yet it does we are
conscious this seems to be a very very
difficult problem
indeed and in the face of this apparent
challenge there are all sorts of
of ways of thinking that are on the menu
and we'll hear about some of these other
parts of this festival one of them is is
pan psychism consciousness is
fundamental and ubiquitous it is in some
sense everywhere and in everything this
sort of explains away the hard problem
because as if consciousness is
fundamental and ubiquitous you no longer
have to explain
how it comes to be for certain physical
systems now the problem with pan
psychism
is not that it sounds crazy it's just
that it's not testable it doesn't lead
to any testable propositions and doesn't
explain anything which is a problem
another
idea out there is that
we're mistaken that there's such a thing
as a hard problem or that a conscious
experience exists in the way that we
tend to think of them that it's really
just the operation of complex mechanisms
and the idea that conscious experiences
there really is a redness to red as we
experience it that's somehow an illusion
now i think this is a very it's like a
powerful medicine you take a little bit
of this it's very useful
because it inoculates us against taking
how things seem
as an insight into how they actually are
take too much of it and i think you end
up
going off the rails in saying that
consciousness doesn't exist in fact
consciousness is the only thing we can
be really sure of
it's without consciousness there's no
world there's no self there's nothing at
all
and this this perspective is often
called illusionism now trying to
navigate between these two extremes is
challenging but that's you know what
i've been trying to do over the years in
an approach that i you know with
tongue-in-cheek called the real problem
of consciousness and the real problem of
consciousness it's not the hard problem
of figuring out how and why it's part of
the universe in the first place chalmers
problem
it's how can mechanisms and processes in
the brain and body explain predict and
control properties of consciousness
whether they are functional like what
can we do because we're conscious i can
do many things when i experience a glass
of water i can pick it up and drink from
it throw it around um
talk to it i can do many things but
critically phenomenological and that's
unfortunately too many syllable word uh
to mean the experiential character of
the conscious experience visual
experiences have a particular feeling
now they're in space they're objects and
people and spaces in between them
emotional experiences have a different
character experiences of free will
have a different character again if we
can understand these differences
instead of treating consciousness as one
big scary mystery
we start chipping away at that mystery
and doing what science has always done
explaining predicting when things happen
and being able to control
things as they appear we control we can
we can do that
we're
constructing a real science of
consciousness it's neither the hard
problem because i'm not trying to say
what is the magic special source that
magics consciousness from their
mechanism and it's not the so-called
easy problems of con of neuroscience
which is basically everything about the
brain that doesn't involve consciousness
at all no we're trying to say these are
the properties of consciousness how do
they relate to underlying mechanisms i'm
certainly not the first person to
propose this approach there are many
precedents and things like
neurophenomenology and so on but the
underlying feeling is instead of solving
this hard problem we'll dissolve it
and there's a historical precedent for
thinking this way
the parallel isn't complete but it's
illuminating and illustrative 150 years
ago people thought that life could never
be explained in terms of mechanisms that
maybe we needed to find some ellen bital
some spark of light some special source
and of course if you treat life as one
big scary mystery that's the temptation
but biologists ended up explaining
different properties of living systems
by different mechanisms in physics and
chemistry and the heart problem of life
was dissolved was not solved now
consciousness is not the same thing as
life there are many differences
the point is that what seems mysterious
from one particular point with the
concepts and tools that you have
may not always seem mysterious
for me this is the way to understand
consciousness to isolate its properties
and account for them so what are the
properties of consciousness
well in the book and in my work with my
lab we divided into three ways more or
less there's conscious level how
conscious you are at any particular time
the difference between
anesthesia and normal conscious
wakefulness or other states like the
psychedelic state
minimally conscious state
there's conscious content
what we are conscious of when we are
conscious
all the objects people places colors
shapes that populate our experience of
the world around us and an important
subset of that
is self the experience of being a self
the self isn't the thing that does the
experiencing the self arises
in experience too
and that is a critical part of what
being consciousness is all about and
it's probably the aspect of
consciousness that each of us clings to
most tightly in different ways
the brain is a prediction machine
and that everything that we perceive
everything experience everything that we
do is a kind of brain-based prediction
now just think about what it means to be
a brain for a minute and let's take
perception as this task of figuring out
what's out there in the world there you
are you're your brain you're locked
inside this bony skull
it's dark in there it's silent all
you've got to go on as a brain are
streams of electrical signals which are
only indirectly related to things in the
world whatever they may be
and from these noisy ambiguous uncertain
electrical signals the brain conjures
forth
a world full of things with positions
and properties how does it do that
the idea and this is an idea that goes
way back in science and in philosophy is
that it's a process of inference of some
kind so by inference i just mean the
brain is making its best guess
about what's out there based on
inherently uncertain noisy ambiguous
data the brain is combining its
expectations
expectations that you're not personally
aware of having that can be built deep
into the circuitry of the brain like
that light comes from above expectations
combines those with sensory data and
then
what you perceive this is the hypothesis
is the content of the brain's
predictions it's not a readout of the
sensory data
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas